foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
I am Rosanna Lockwood in for peers on
uncensored tonight ITV announces an
external review into Philip schofield's
departure from this morning as the
broadcaster prepares to be quizzed by
NPS over the way that's daytime TV show
was run tomorrow Mark the start of pride
month Bart is the rainbow Alliance at
risk from radical and extreme voices
within the trans community and is it
time for LGB to drop the team we're
going to be debating that the Duke of
Sussex back in the spotlight again is he
ever out of it facing more questions
about how his US Visa got approved the
loose-lipped prince admitting to taking
a variety of drugs of course in his
Memoir spare but did he declare that
when he moved across the pond
and could psychedelic drugs like magic
mushrooms be the key to treating
depression former Chief medical advice
to the UK government Sir Patrick balance
seems to think so is it safe or even
sensible to make such suggestions we'll
get to look at that later in the show
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored with
Rosanna Lockwood ah it's so bright in
the studio this evening isn't it wait to
see Esther as well good evening welcome
to Piers Morgan uncensored with miradell
local there she's splendon in Orange we
are going to start with the Scofield
Saga deepening it tonight with ITV
announcing an external review Into the
disgraced Stars departure from this
morning now the Network's chief
executive Dame Carolyn McCall says a
barrister has been instructed to carry
out a review of The Facts adding that
ITV is taking this matter very seriously
so all the broadcasters top bosses
finally taking control of what has
seemed over the last few days or so to
be an unmanageable situation
or does this make matters much worse for
ITV to discuss all of this I'm joined by
Alexander dos Santos who's a barrister
specializing in inquest and inquiries
really Public Law and professional
discipline also media commentator Nigel
Paulie joining us and in the studio of
me talk to me contributor Esther cracker
you've got a little preview of the
orange there looking gorgeous Esther as
always Uh Kevin you're looking gorgeous
too it'd be remiss of me yeah these
standard male issue of pale blue shirt
and dark suits
it works it works for beers it can work
for you too like let's head over to
Alexander first to get a little bit of a
kind of background on this what
essentially is happening here is ITV
held internal investigations that's uh
Nigel I'll come to you then seeing as
you've been given to me first ITV said
they were going to give us internal
investigations or they had them but that
they were cleared they couldn't find
evidence of wrongdoing and now they've
appointed a barrister to give us this
extra Journal Review let's see whether
that makes a difference Alexander talk
to us a little bit about this about the
process of that
um well they've instructed an
independent things Council to as I
understand it establish the facts now
there's been quite a lot of
um media commentary about
um the background of what mayor knows
have happened and what the ITV are very
keen to do clearly is have an
independent party examine all the
evidence that's available and try and
form a view as to what actually has
taken place now what we don't know at
this stage is the scope of that inquiry
that'll be quite important because that
will determine how far and wide the
king's Council will be looking at the
evidence and wider issues so we know for
example there was a previous review Into
the allegations made by DR range but in
the circumstances here and clearly what
we're going to have is someone look at
what was known when by whom and
establish essentially a timeline of
facts up to the point when Mrs Schofield
left ITV so it's there first of all to
give some Independence to the review and
secondly to bring to bear the skills
that the king's Council in question will
bring in terms of getting to the bottom
of the evidence and looking at what more
might be needed so it's there to help
hopefully draw a line under things right
TV also to provide answers to not just
um the public but also those who have a
stake in ITV and and it's reputation but
it's there essentially to try and get
the best
um version of those facts will it make a
difference
to the extent that you're going to get
all kinds of speculation generally what
it will bring is a great deal of
Integrity to the review so what I will
expect is that the king's Council will
where there's uh deficiency or a lack of
evidence and you'll have someone who's
very skilled to get into the bottom of
accounts and whether or not they're
misleading or not and also why this is
said to be wrong because there doesn't
seem to be a consistent message as to
what Mr Scofield's done wrong different
people have different views as to what
it is and when it's occurred and so it'd
be very useful from that perspective
Nigel coming to you now is it just that
ITV doesn't have any other way to go at
this point we know that certain members
of the management are going to be hauled
before a government committee next
Tuesday so they just had to do this
they do this it's it's calming things
down I think that's the basic situation
they're trying to um protect the brand
as the share price tumbled yet further
it's got another 11 pence in a week and
advertisers are getting Twitchy and
really this is throwing Phyllis
Schofield I think under a bus it's
protecting the executives and protecting
itv's brand Jane multi KC uh she was
involved in the Yorkshire Cricket she
represents the ECB in the racism uh uh
investigation we saw Michael Vaughan
eventually being cleared of of racism uh
she's represented Manchester City and
looked into
um sex abuse claims there she's very
skilled and I'd imagine the people being
questioned would be very worried about
the depth of where she's going and
they've made it very clear it's
surrounding Phillip schofield's
statement and his exit so the spotlight
is very much back on him rather than ITV
yeah let's talk about the people being
worried in this Kevin uh coming to you
as another media voice on this associate
editor of the mirror because
if you know these people are going to be
hauled up in front of a committee I can
imagine that Dame Carolyn uh McCall DB
chief executive of ITV which probably
doesn't want to be sat there in front of
that committee we've got her letter this
evening that she sent to the Barrister
where she said the point of this
external review is to get to the facts
of the investigation how worried do you
think she is right now well she's been
forced to do this really the internal
inquiry failed to get to the truth they
say because both parties lied but it was
an open secret about the relationship
and it's all about the pat it's about
the power relationship between a very
senior boss Philip scorfield and
somebody who's young and potentially
vulnerable in a workplace and a company
has a wider responsibility to people it
employers not to be a bishop and get on
a moral high horse or anything like that
it is you know you just do have a
responsibility so clearly should be
worried now you take back control at
some extent by having this external
review and it can say to MPS we've got a
review we've got to wait for that but
you can also lose control because you
cannot dictate the outcome I'm sure she
studied all the documents and she thinks
she's got a good argument herself she'll
be in the clear but somebody's going to
carry the can at the end of the day so
I'm just going to be full of school if
you look he's throwing himself under the
bus by saying I lied uh and and I
shouldn't have but I I recall Dominic
Robb who was a deputy prime minister I
said yeah let's have a barrister
investigate allegations about me
bullying because I think I'll be cleared
then he lost his job because the report
didn't come out the way he thought it
I'm glad you brought up that analogy
because Esther you know you've heard my
argument on this already this week which
is this isn't a crisis in the NHS it's
not a crisis in Westminster this is a
crisis on a television show yeah of a
publicly listed but private broadcaster
isn't the BBC so is it still too much
Mountain over mole hill or do you think
there really is a cause here for this
type of investigation and inquiry I
think it's you're right it's not the BBC
and I I do think that we we are risking
throwing Phillips Schofield on the bus
now I do think what he did was wrong he
knows what he did was wrong he was
clearing the position of power he and I
think the biggest issue is the his
Connections in getting this young one at
his job at ITV because it was clearly
that's what got him to that position so
we we know this was a young person who
was enamored by Phillip Schofield and
that power Dynamic was very toxic
however we have to remember that you
know at some point there's going to be a
situation of you know vultures circling
the prey here he has come out he has
said he he he was wrong and he lied and
all of that I think we have to remember
that he's still a human being and it's
this kind of bullying that took took out
Caroline Flack now he his mental health
must be under enormous amounts of strain
because while he was wrong you know he's
lost so much he's lost you know the his
The credibility that he's built over a
30-year career he's no longer hosting
that award show which named Escape me
he's been dropping exactly the princess
trust he's been dropped by yeah you know
and and the runner has also you know
brought the brunt of this he's had his
privacy invaded in so many different
ways I think enough is enough this
public inquiry is not necessary this is
not the BBC and I think it's highlighted
what happens when you have inappropriate
like
because this has been weeks now Alistair
Campbell Layla spin doctor I always said
if a story goes on for 10 days you're in
big trouble so he's gonna I think I
think they're trying to cauterize the
wound but they're not quite sure how
it's gonna yeah how it's going to end
and my thing is how can what can you
actually do everyone knew about this
there's not really much this inquiry
will reveal every single person let's go
back to Alex De Santos on this and talk
a little bit about how the investigation
acquiry process works then if um as we
as led to believe by a lot of Gossip
obviously and here's saying that's what
it is but that a lot of people knew
about this but when you get down to the
fact of the matter investigating
something like this hearsay doesn't fly
does it and they can't question
Freelancers for example you know kind of
temporary contract workers
well I think I hit face I'm I'm like a
trial hearsay may be relevant miscible
but it's all the circumstances are
relevant as to what weight that should
be attached to that so I think what
you'll find the case is very good at is
separating out gossip and rumor from
what is actually a sustainable fact I
think it's important to note though also
that barrister-led inquiries are not
actually uncommon in the corporate world
and so before people start to jump
assume because a Barrister's being hired
that that means there's a real problem
um it's quite common for companies to
hire barristers to investigate any kind
of error or wrongdoing internally so
um what I think you'll find this council
is very good at doing is just separating
the reliable from the unreliable
evidence and ascertaining what really
can help decide what occurred so
there'll be a lot of skill brought and I
think it'll be useful and of course the
case will have no skin in the game
we'll just have to obviously await the
findings as well look Nigel I want to
come back to you on the important
point that mental health in all of this
talking about Phillips game but of
course the young man at the center of it
all as well who on this network we've
kept very much Anonymous as far as we
can when talking about this because that
is a key point in all of this isn't it
we're talking about gossip we're talking
about people's Affairs relationships
real life things I mean you must have
seen this a lot in your career uh what
what are you making of the way that it's
being spoken about and the possible um
real world effects it could have
well I've only been incredulous that
Vanessa said that it's not the BBC so
therefore it's not important the CBI was
a public listed company and wrongdoings
were happening there and quite rightly
heads rolled the mental health is very
much at the center of the core values of
ITV Carolyn McCall Dane Carolyn McCall
is very very
um hot on mental health issues this this
young person has been through a lot
schofield's 30 or 40-year career winning
16 days and and the the you know he's
still suffering he's still losing the
frizzy's trust is why and various other
things he has lost a lot but if you lie
to your boss your partner your work
partner at your bosses and your agents
then I think you lose the sympathy of
the room when things come around and
this will you know this inquiry will
look
is based on the balance of probabilities
by the way it's not based as the virus
they will know it's not like a court of
law where it's based on fact two people
saying something could be seen as the
balance of probability something
happened coming to rather than one
person's word Nigel saying sorry we've
got a bit of a connection issue with
your sound there but where your points
were made very clearly even so coming to
Kevin on that as well and your media
career in terms of the way this is being
talked about the way that Schofield is
being characterized do you think it's
fair I mean we have had first-hand
accounts many that he wasn't a very
pleasant person to work with but there
are lots of investment banking bosses no
no I think that's right
we shouldn't be Public Enemy Number One
it's not Vladimir Putin he hasn't uh
invaded a country or anything I think
you've got to have some sense of
proportion but at the same time he was
an incredibly successful TV figure who
people felt they had a relationship of
trust with as he was presented on this
morning sitting next to Holly Willoughby
who will also have questions to answer
about actually what she knew or didn't
know I'm sure whether her career is
probably a little a little question mark
next to it in Truth and a lot of other
people some people are attacking from
the outside are very bitter they used to
work on the program they were moved on
so they're settling scores you can hear
you know axes being sharpened but now I
I feel some sympathy for Schofield now
because his entire world has collapsed
yeah he's lost his job he's status he's
standing
is it not just but also doing something
as an adult in a marriage but it's it's
a proportionality here's the thing he
did absolutely something wrong I said
from the beginning when this happened I
felt so sorry for his wife
um and I think she's been very
reasonable you talked about access being
sharpened if my husband did that to me
um axes will be sharpened
um but the reality is to lose or
basically your entire livelihood I don't
know if that's
that's fair
um he he did lie he did do something
very wrong there was there was a huge
imbalance in the nature of the
relationship that he was in in terms of
power but I don't think it's fair for
him to lose all of this and then you
know for the circle for the vultures to
keep circling the prey in this manner
Carolyn McCall in her letter to offcom
the culture committee chair and the
culture secretary said they were also
continue to office offering support to
the young man now what about his state
of mind and how he is we know he doesn't
want the publicity we know it's a big
burden he can never work again yeah
really it's it's very it's very
difficult to because you don't want to
identify him because there are real
privacy issues there but at the moment
Schofield is carrying the cow yeah he
said look I I lied I lied and so you
deserve some credit for that the
admission was something you don't see
that level of honesty
it was that so we're given that but uh
on the Simplicity side of things I'm not
sure I'm totally with you look oh no all
four of you gave us some really good
insights on this it continues to evolve
we keep thinking we're done with the
story and more drops every day but
thanks ever so much Nigel Alex as well
down the line with us stay with us here
on uncensored after reports of strains
within the lgbtq community uh we're
asking should LGBT drop the T I'm gonna
be debating that next
foreign
[Music]
first lady thank you both very much
indeed prime minister thank you very
much for inviting me into your your lair
here
who comes out of the Mad team everyone
has something it's magic
the time say something because I like it
as simple as that I don't say that in
public
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the show Rosanna
Lockwood in for Piers Morgan online
center tonight now tomorrow marks the
start of pride month when I found out
we'd be debating the argument that there
might be strains in the lgbtq community
on the show tonight I've got to be
honest my heart sank a little bit and
that's not because of any issues I've
got with this it's just that as a
straight woman I feel it's not my debate
I also have many friends many family
members and loved ones in my life that
are gay or might identify with this
community as I'm sure you do too and I
always carry them with me in my mind
when I approach these topics you know
how it goes at the moment quote when we
were growing up it was just LGB you're
here now it's lgbtq plus plus
Etc or even questions about why is there
a whole pride month now no matter your
personal views social media algorithms
will no doubt be serving you this type
of commentary at the moment and when you
read that or listen to that does it
leave you feeling wiser and more
tolerant or suspicious and Confused that
the actions of the trans activists
protesting outside the Oxford Union
speech yesterday move you in any
direction or is your mind on other
things at the moment an argument is now
being made in some quarters the extreme
members of the trans Community are
alienating support for the wider
Collective that has done so much to
improve the position of minorities in
this country and around the world so
tonight we're going to be asking members
of the lgbtq community or the rainbow
alliances are sometimes called if they
feel at risk from radical and extreme
voices within or is this simply a
further attack on trans people I think
it is best that we hear from people in
the community and understand what it all
means to them and before we go on let's
remember that pride month honors the
Stonewall Uprising in New York in 1969
that happened when violent tensions
between police and patrons of a gay bar
in Manhattan led to days of pro test and
unrest it was actually a watershed
moment in a movement that led to the Gay
Pride marches that we see around the
world today mostly intolerant Western
countries a lot of us were familiar with
that it's also an annual moment to
remember people who fought and fight for
the right to live as they are now I say
all this because it is a sensitive
subject you can tell I know that it is
and I'm pleased to say joining me to
debate all this this evening is social
media influencer Ollie London a man who
is in the process of detransitioning
from a trans woman back to a man
and also by veteran lgbtq activist Peter
tatchel and comedian and radio presenter
James Barr familiar face on this show as
well also joining us down the line Bev
Jackson co-founder of LGB Alliance which
promotes the rights of lesbians
bisexuals and gay men Bev thank you ever
so much we're gonna start in the studio
I want to come to
all of you join me here you heard what I
just said there Peter coming to you
first
am I over egging it by saying I'm not
allowed to talk about this because I'm a
straight woman
I think you're entitled to your point of
view but obviously please listen to what
LGBT plus people are saying on this
particular issue it is very clear there
are more than a thousand LGBT plus
organizations in the UK mostly LGBT
lesbian gay and bisexual and almost
without exception they support including
trans people within our Coalition and
trans people have been here right from
the beginning they were outside the
Stonewall Inn protesting in 1969 which
saw the birth of the modern lesbian Gay
Liberation movement they were also in
the London Gay Liberation Front in 1970
and 71 when we began all that half
century and more ago so trans people
have always been part of our community
and we think we should all stick
together united we stand divided we fall
James come here because you're nodding
along there is a
so then his experienced to even suggest
that there are these arguments happening
that there are divisions or strains yeah
absolutely I completely disagree with
what you were saying I don't think there
are divisions or strains within our
community I think there's a small
faction of people outside of the
community who want to create a moral
Panic about trans people for no reason
other than the fact that they are hiding
behind that to push forwards their
right-wing agenda and actually it
disgusts me because you know we have a
lot of Rights in this country as lgbtq
plus people it's outrageous to suggest
that we close the door behind us and
stop trans people getting through as
well now what about uh sort of thoughts
when I was approaching this show this
evening was that we didn't have a trans
person who is remaining trans coming to
be part of this debate so I've heard
from you both on this but obviously
Ollie you have are in the process
detransitioning from trans so I don't
know whether the trans Community will
feel they have I think I just want to
interrupt and Ollie You can disagree but
is it not right to say that you're
de-transitioning from being transracial
not transgender did you ever come out of
transgender words how long were you
transgender for a year because I'd argue
that if you were a transgender woman
you're therefore a woman and if you're
saying you're not transgender now
therefore you were never transgender no
I struggled with uh my identity my whole
life and you know it's the trans
Community they're always saying oh you
shouldn't question someone if they feel
trans if that's how they identify you're
not allowed to question them so why
because ID transition why would you
question I'm not questioning that I'm
sorry that you went through that but
that doesn't mean that everyone has the
same experience as you correct everybody
has a different in spirits and they're
entitled to that but my issue is the
trans activists that have hijacked the
LGBT community and are causing real harm
to the LGBT community by pushing gender
ideology on children by forcing women
out of women's spaces that is my issue I
don't have an issue of trans people I
have many trans friends my issue is with
the radical gender ideology so do you
think there is cases for the argument
then that this show is premised around
this evening that there is a bit of
strain in the community there's
definitely strain I mean look there are
people that say that sexuality and
gender identity should not be conflated
and I think the real issue is the more
extreme elements of the trans activists
that are pushing this agenda that are
pushing for all these things on children
pushing for hormones some kids some
puberty bloggers that's the real
question again if you spend like 75 000
pounds on surgery to look like a member
yes so should we not be talking about
BTS indoctrine engine you could say the
same about someone that's non-binary you
know you could say are they not allowed
to identify as how they feel that's all
I was doing I was just saying the same
logic I'm using the same logic as woke
people you can identify as anywhere
lgbtqi plus 2s teaspoon it if somebody
can identify as two spirit I can choose
whatever I want I was struggling with my
identity I've dealt with those issues
and now I'm trying to help children the
LGBT community should be coming together
to help children to find a solution to
support trans people as well people that
have struggled their whole life but in
your job I support that but we also need
to respect women men shouldn't be in
women's spaces men shouldn't be in
women's sports we need to respect all
people I'm gonna come to Bev now because
uh Bev has also been kind enough to join
us this evening you've been listening to
that hope you heard all of it Bev
um yeah go ahead interest yeah yeah
happy too happy to join in this
discussion uh I'd like to respond to a
few of the things but first I think I
should fear up that the title is perhaps
a little bit um uh misleading I think
this is not a question about the LGB
dropping the T but why the tea was added
to LGB in the first place and people
perhaps think that it's always been
there but in fact in the UK it was only
added in 2015 and
um that no lesbians will consultant at
the time the consultation was all with
trans groups and I think you would have
found that lesbians would have been very
unhappy in fact many lesbians were
unhappy when they discovered that the
tea was added LGB is about relationships
it's about love it's about sex it's
about who you're attracted to are you
attracted to men are you attracted to
women or are you attracted to both it's
very clear sexual orientation T and Q
and all the other letters that have been
added since then are about identity
issues they're completely separate and
it's caused a lot of confusion we've
seen how much confusion it's caused with
the labor politicians trying the
desperately to avoid saying what a woman
is and that's quite comic but it's also
caused a lot of tragedy particularly for
lesbians it's no a coincidence that LGB
Alliance was founded by Kate Harris and
me two lesbians and our CEO is a lesbian
and also the chair of the board is a
lesbian it's lesbians who have suffered
from the addition of the tea
um to LGB and I think you're subtitles
perhaps should be reading campaigners
argue that the gay community has been
hijacked but anyway so what has happened
with uh with lesbians let me explain why
I'm saying that it's a tragedy for
lesbians what we're seeing at the moment
and you can look that thousands hundreds
of thousands of lesbians are um having
their breasts removed you can see tens
of thousands
um fundraising on GoFundMe to have their
breasts removed and um this is because
it's no longer cool to be lesbian in
fact I spoke to a 19 year old recently
who said that throughout her Secondary
School she'd been told she must be a boy
she'd must be a boy because she fell for
girls this is the kind of homophobia
that is being taught at schools taught
online and spread online and spread by
peers so that lesbians don't feel
comfortable about being lesbian anymore
this kind of homophobia is is a real
tragedy and in fact the fact that it is
being propagated it I think it calls for
a public inquiry how is it possible ten
years ago you would have been thought a
bit weird if you'd said that men can can
change into women and women can change
it to men and these days You're called
weird If you deny it the fact is you
can't change sex children shouldn't be
taught that they they can change sex
it's like teaching them yeah they can
fly they might jump out of the window
and find they can't fly and they can't
change so many you've brought up a lot
of points there I'm gonna say and that
is the kind of but the issue with this
conversation as a whole because we're
talking about so many different types of
people I mean in and of itself I find it
fascinating that I'm talking about
lesbians
the examples that Bev and Ollie give are
totally unrepresentative yes they happen
and I condemn them but they're not
representative Britain's biggest lesbian
celebration lesbian visibility week
which took place in April was inclusive
of trans and non-binary woman it was
celebrated by lesbians lesbians
themselves wanted trans and non-binary
people to be part of of this celebration
I listened to you without interruption
can you please show courtesy be polite
and courteous
um you know those lesbian women who are
behind lesbian visibility week they
included trans and non-binary people
with the support of The Wider lesbian
Community there's a small number of
lesbians who disagree with this trend I
accept that they're entitled to their
point of view but they're not
representative of the wider lesbian
Community I want to come to James now
you wanted to jump in Bev we will come
back to you we will come back to bed but
we'll just go to the studio James you
wanted to jump in I was like no I'm and
I just broadly have a question do you
find this conversation is gonna
obviously we're not gonna find a
solution or resolution but is it useful
to talk about no it's not I actually
find it incredibly boring and I think
the stuff that Bev is spouting is
transphobia and I genuinely believe that
it's it's kind of amusing that you're
talking about uh homophobia because
really you're just being transphobic and
those two things don't cancel each other
out they are not helpful at all and
you're talking about children being
indoctrinated it's Insanity it's
literally not happening there's no proof
of that happening um Ollie
why are you bringing up conversations
like that when you have not had that
yourself I mean can only not speak to
his personal experience well his
personal experience is literally wanting
to look like an Asian this is this is a
great but we're not talking about
banning BTS sorry am I allowed to speak
this is a great example of woke people
you do you shout people don't give
people you know talking of inclusivity
what about including women in this
conversation what about including women
in women are included in this college
here suggesting that she supports let me
speak trans activists are constantly
pushing at women just yes they're at the
Oxford Union a trans activist blew
themselves to the floor because they
didn't want the woman to speak about
women's rights is that fair do you think
it's fair that women aren't allowed to
have a conversation that their movement
is just suddenly hijacked they can't do
Sports they're scared to speak up
athletes are scared to speak up in case
they're deemed transphobic for saying
the simple fact that biological men have
a competitive advantage we know that so
let's let women speak let's stop going
on about what transactions
letting women speak let's let's get out
to Bev go on then Bev
yeah I I want to say that that
um first of all but we tried very hard
to do context and well when they changed
uh and when Stonewall changed all the
other uh um organizations that have been
uh gay rights groups around the country
all changed to focus on gender identity
and uh we tried to get them to to
discuss the problems but they wouldn't
well we eventually had to form LGB
Alliance which goes back to the roots of
standing up for sexual orientation the
second we formed LGB Alliance people and
you can listen please listen to this we
were deluged by messages from lesbians
all over the world thank God you're here
I have felt so isolated thank God when
are you setting up in Canada when are
you setting up in Australia thank God
can I what can I do to help and the
reason that we were able to grow so
quickly we were just two women two old
dikes yes we had no money we had no
external funding and all these this
nonsense is about right-wing funding is
it's complete nonsense we were two women
who worked our asses off seven days a
week 16 hours a day and or for all these
lesbians who contacted us and they
joined us and we built a wonderful
organization of some of the the clubs
people in the world Bev you and I were
both in the Gay Liberation Front in the
early 1970s and as you well know
prominent among the Gay Liberation for
activists were trans women like Carla
and Rachel they were prominent now
movement they were featured in the gay
uh the come together newspaper it was
part of our wider movement and just as
we challenged premises that refused to
serve lesbian gay and bisexual people we
also had a very famous sit-in at a cafe
in pivoli Circus which refused to serve
trans people we saw these two different
struggles as being different but also
having communality the common experience
of prejudice discrimination
we should stay together now we should
stand up for each other and not divide
yeah
I'm very sorry to ask Peter I need to
ask Peter if he's read Stuart feathers
book blowing the lid badge you can ask a
piece of that on the DMV after the show
unfortunately we are fresh we should
read it we are fresh out of time look we
really appreciate you joining the
conversation this evening and to our
panelists in the studios well I've been
fascinated by this especially on the Eid
of pride month talking about the
division but hopefully a bit more Unity
it's been great to have all your
insights thanks so much for your time
a little nonsense or next tonight is
Prince Harry in hot water over his
history of drug taking and his U.S visa
we'll be hearing from the man leading an
appeal to unseal his immigration records
coming up next
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
foreign
[Music]
may have found himself in hot water yet
again but this time for being too honest
the Duke of Sussex facing yet more
questions over how he got his U.S visa
approved after admitting to taking a
variety of drugs in his autobiography
spare Piers Morgan's favorite bedtime
read the Duke of Sussex revealing of
course in this book that he tried
cocaine smoked marijuana and
experimented with magic mushrooms here's
a snippet from that audiobook
psychedelics did me some good as well
I'd experimented with them over the
years for fun but now I'd begun to use
them therapeutically of course I had
been doing cocaine around this time
at someone's Country House during a
shooting weekend I've been offered a
line and I'd done a few more since
there you go literally in black and
white talking about his drug use now
conservative think tank the Heritage
Foundation is appealing a U.S court to
unseal Prince Harry's immigration
records in the hope that he may get
kicked out of the country as a result
I'm now joined to discuss this by author
and cultural commentator Bonnie Greer
always so good on U.S issues and Prince
Harry former head of Royal protection
dye Davis also joining us I will be out
to you shortly but first let's head over
to Nile Gardner whose organization is
the one the Heritage Foundation
appealing to unseal Prince Harry's
immigration records now let's just start
simply what's your motivation for doing
this
well thanks for having me on the show
today and uh basically we are calling
for accountability and transparency on
the part of the the by Administration we
believe there is a clear public interest
in the release of Prince Harry's
immigration records especially uh in
light of the extensive Revelations of
illegal drug use uh in spur and we want
to ensure of course that Prince Harry
was honest and fully transparent in his
immigration application to the United
States we also want to ensure that there
is no preferential treatment given
towards a Prince Harry everyone should
be treated equally by by the law and the
Heritage Foundation believes strongly in
the robust application of immigration
law we have been the leading voice I'd
say in the United States in many decades
in support of strong uh application of
U.S immigration laws and we are of the
view that Prince Harry should not be in
any way treated uh differently to
anybody else applying to the United
States
remember the royal family you seem to
think that he got preferential treatment
by the Biden Administration and there
might be some evidence in these unsealed
documents that prove that but I just I'm
interested in your motivations as a
British person over in the US doing this
to another Brit
well British Crossing but I have U.S
citizenship as well uh and uh you know
my my motivation here is to ensure that
immigration laws applied by U.S
authorities that that's the motivation
here Prince Harry of course has become a
huge public figure in the United States
uh he is a a big figure on both sides to
the Atlantic he's a household name uh in
America there is intense public interest
actually in this uh upcoming uh court
hearing uh and opinion polls have shown
produced by Newsweek for example that a
majority of Americans want to see the
release of Prince Harry's immigration
record so this has been very closely
followed by millions of Americans uh and
uh it's our view that no one should be
should be uh treated uh in a
preferential away here the law should be
applied equally to everybody regardless
of celebrity status or or membership of
the royal family uh and Prince Harry
should be treated no different
especially in light of the extensive
drug use Revelations that he made
himself yeah no doubt there are
extensive drug use Revelations let's
speak to another American citizen here
in the studio in London
and everything else in between and of
course you don't speak on behalf of all
Americans you have your own views but
what's your reaction to Nile well that's
very fascinating to hear now actually
describe a proxy war between the
Heritage Foundation and the body
Administration with for all Harry as the
hostage it's going to be really really
interesting uh to watch this uh roll out
uh the Heritage Foundation has become if
I can use the term more Maga since uh
the Trump Administration they are the
number one conservative thing tank they
built the Reagan Administration and now
they become all Maga and now they've got
Paul Harry and their site as a way to
fight actually the Homeland Security
Department uh because parts of the
Republican Party want to impeach the
head of the home of Homeland Security so
Harry's in the middle of all of this and
I think and you know as far as now
saying that all America wants to know
his drug records really so
um
I hopefully for Harry's sake that
everything is sort of lined up as it
should be but I support the deal the
Department of Homeland Security's
refusal to unseal the records because
they don't do that this is always at the
discretion of the immigration department
immigration officer and so it's going to
be an interesting battle we'll come back
to now to get his response to uh your
suggestions there uh of how this is all
being used but let's come out to die
because you're a former head of Royal
protection and let's just talk about if
if Harry uh you know the drug use is
there and if he does loot his U.S sort
of residency right should he come back
to the UK
well it's an interesting dilemma whether
he wants to come back I don't know I
suspect he doesn't uh given all the fura
that's going on and of course he's in
court himself next week which will be a
very interesting scenario to see him
actually in the witness box one of the
first Royals other than his great great
uh grandfather actually going into a
witness box so it'll be very interesting
my perspective is is that he's a
household name both here and America and
if he admits to taking cocaine and Other
Drugs he's at the end of a criminal
organization who Thrive unfortunately on
those who want to take drugs in this
country and indeed in America it's an
epidemic so for him to come out in my
view foolishly to actually articulate
the fact that he's been taking it not
once but not twice but on a regular
basis I think is extremely foolish and
again I I wondered who counseled him
that was a sensible thing to do
it does seem diet that there is a bit of
a lack of counsel there look I'm really
sorry we aren't just so so close out of
time I want to give Nile just
opportunity to say is what Bonnie's
saying true about your motivations
well it was quite great to listen to
Bonnie and I but I have to disagree with
with Bonnie's comments that you know
Prince Harry is not some sort of uh
hostage here
um you know Prince Harry is is a huge
public figure in his in his own right uh
I think there's a clear public interest
here
um and uh and I I do think that uh as
well the buying Administration uh needs
to operate in a transparent constructive
manner If Prince Harry has nothing to
hide here he should fully support the
release of his own records
many many immigration records have been
released in fact Kamala Harris's
mother's immigration records were
released so many uh individuals well we
will see if the Biden Administration do
play ball I'm really sorry to cut you
off we are fresh out of time uh thanks
so much for all three of you for giving
your views this evening uncensored next
tonight so much more drugs to discuss
magic mushrooms the answer to tackling
depression former UK chief medical
officer Patrick balance seems to think
so but would we be opening up a huge can
of psychedelic worms we'll be debating
that next
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
coming up on the talk ITV bosses order a
review into its handling of Phillip
schofield's Affair Boris Johnson hands
over his WhatsApp messages ahead of the
covid inquiry deadline and the US
government has questions to answer over
Prince Harry's Visa all of that at nine
o'clock
[Music]
thank you
well we've got something fascinating for
you now so Patrick Valance the former
Chief medical advisor to the government
during covid is back in the news saying
when it comes to Britain's mental health
epidemic there's a lot of scientific
enthusiasm for using psychedelic drugs
in the treatment of depression PTSD and
anxiety and he's encouraging more
research into that in America the trend
is already well underway so is this
something we really should be tuning
into here in the UK or a little bit far
out man joining me here in the studio to
discuss all of this Dr David Eric so
Clinical Director of the center for
psychedelic research at Imperial College
London and talk to if you contributor
Esther cracker joining us once again but
let's head out first to Denver Colorado
and speak to Tracy T who's the founder
of the group mums on mushrooms hi Tracy
thanks so much for making time for us
just tell us what moms or mushrooms is
all about
uh moms on mushrooms was created to form
a online digital community and
educational platform for the safe and
intentional use of micro dosing
specifically psilocybin and uh I did
this because I feel like this medicine
really hits different when you're a
mother and we need to have education
access to resources and learn in
communities to work safely with this
medicine so psilocybin is an active
ingredient in magic mushrooms to my
knowledge and how do you think is how do
you think it improves your life as a
mother
um gosh as a mother as a woman as a
human what we've found is and what
certainly what I've experienced with
microdosing psilocybin is just an
overall better sense of well-being
um I feel less anxious
um more creative more present more
present with my family
um less reactive and uh it just sort of
Smooths out the rough edges are you have
you
microsylosobin today recently would you
say you'll own it now
I did not micro dose today
um you don't ever want to micro dose
every day I always want to take days off
yeah right you're not high so I never
you're when you microdose I'm never high
so you wouldn't know even if I did and
that is what I typically taken
yeah that is definitely worth mentioning
uh micro dose is a sub-perceptual dose
so um usually around one gram of magic
mushrooms is where you see you start to
feel it in your body maybe see some
hallucinogenics a microdose is anywhere
from 50 milligrams to around 150
milligrams so a very small dose and
again that's very important for moms on
mushrooms to reiterate because obviously
we don't need mothers uh feeling the
effects of a of a psychedelic drug while
we're taking care of our kids yeah of
course Tracy it's really good to get
your insights we've got a doctor in the
studio I want to come to just to respond
to some of the comments right there talk
to us a little bit about the research
that's going into these psychedelic
compounds yeah so what Tracy is talking
about is micro dosing which is a
psychedelic microwave so same compounds
but using a tiny dose as Tracy was
talking about and it's repeated so
frequent intestines over a longer period
so the main bulk of the research that is
most progressed is actually a different
version of it which is a full dose so
where people actually have changed
perception so Ultra State of
Consciousness is sort of awake dream
like State and that is very few sessions
and then it is after people have been
sort of prepared well for the session
psychologically supported and will
psychological integration after us
that's quite different use of the same
drugs completely different dose and much
fewer sessions and that is what is
really showing a lot of promise at the
moment we have done trials the first in
decades of any psychedelic intervention
for depression we have done at Imperial
we have worked on these compounds for
more than decade doing a lot of brain
Imaging trying to understand how these
drugs work try to understand the brain
better try to understand the conditions
better and overall with these full dose
which is different for microdosing but
with the same compounds such as
psilocybin the results are very very
promising for depression in particular
but also even upcoming data data that is
evolving for other conditions addictions
OCD anxiety PTSD MDMA is being is very
progressed in the development for PTSD
as well
um well I think sort of one of the
obvious hurdles to this becoming
mainstream is obviously social stigma
will come to you Esther or that lined up
for that but there are any other hurdles
why is is there lack of research I mean
it sounds like there are benefits here
yeah I mean obviously this dick mess
around with these compounds and that has
probably made it a bit difficult early
on to actually restart and reopen this
research but I would say at the moment I
think Regulators even politicians are
starting to waking up a bit and say this
should be prioritized maybe the
scheduling should be Revisited and
Regulators are also because of a big big
gap in mental health treatments that I
fish in a lot of people suffering
millions of people suffering severe
mental illness around the world and no
40 or more are not responding well are
not actually responding to the
treatments that are available therefore
there's a big gap therefore it's being
supported with a new paradigm and it's
an interesting Paradigm where
pharmacology medicine meets psychology
because it's a mixed model which is very
appealing and very interesting and
really does at this point look promising
not just in our trials at Imperial other
centers are doing the same thing and
showing the same results Pharma
companies smaller ones so far are doing
important work and sharing the same
thing we could talk about it all day I
think because it is fascinating let us
do you know how this goes we're very
short on time but are you convinced by
the arguments here I know you have eyes
on I am uh was I don't because I don't
think it's a bunch of high people
walking around like I don't think that's
we're gonna have a bunch of High zombies
um you know crashing our streets but um
I do think it is good to have an option
in a wide range of treatments for
various mental health issues
particularly depression because what you
tend to have is people are over medical
eyes they stay on the same
antidepressant for years and they just
became you know numb zombies
um but I do think there should be a
stress on physical health as well of
course which is you know linked to
mental health it's one of those debates
you don't want to have at the end of the
show that is it from us thanks so much
to our contributors on this whatever
you're up to tonight make sure it's
uncensored good night
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]